I got a winter winter okay ah Jace uh
hello little one wow are you that I
kidding lovely boy uh-oh Chet's a bigger
tragedy than joel this won't last very
long ah ok never seen anyone Hank's
something you'll just start like ain't
gonna get shake I got it back um I feel
like [ __ ] right now I won't lie oh oh
hello hello I gotta find out where this
dude goes how they get al awesome last
time ok yes I guess [ __ ] con artist I
got this [ __ ] ok ok come on come on I
[ __ ] missed it he's serious thing
last night played as I [ __ ] got him
already got where'd he go
where's that [ __ ] a senior arunya Oh
Darius days okay let's see how close we
get to this [ __ ] nice and steady I got
him out he is running oh he is running
like my first wife I'm she's still alive
no I mean it sound like I could I talk
it now sham and she actually shot me and
then ran there's that thank you that's
gonna be a twister dear where are you
where are you I say a [ __ ] easy what
good is he oh come on Lily [ __ ] wrist
that I should like a [ __ ] hundred
arrows of this [ __ ] yeah where is this
[ __ ] oh yeah um where is this [ __ ] I'm
a lot how's that him uh-huh nothing to
see here are you saying oh man
definitely get him pretty good that we
got uh shed he's spotting it's that time
of the month where is he where's that
[ __ ] I can smell him
huh are you [ __ ] oh yeah
there's a [ __ ] lose them is he like
up [ __ ] lost up my [ __ ] lost of it
I and it won't see a [ __ ] dare on
here stag anyone i'm looking for a deer
how can i check this [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
up i'm gonna starve this winter now you
know what this way mercy where's oh
here's what ok ok and I've gone far now
you know what they say up doing the pink
in foreign the stink I think that
applies here somehow oh sure how though
ah yes please
all of the mode shut erica is cut soon I
finally after all these [ __ ] years
forgot a little shaken everything's cool
this place is not creepy at all that
meets her dear where are you what's
going on here active minor holy [ __ ] all
right oh I almost choked up to meet
route
I make sure [ __ ] dad hello sir yep
saw me who's there come out hello we
just want to talk any sudden moves I put
one right between your eyes ditto for
buddy boy over there ditto what do you
want name's David this here's my friend
James but from a larger group women
children we're all very very hungry so
am i woman and children all very hungry
too well huh maybe we could trade you
for some of that meat there what do you
need weapons ammo Taelons medicine you
have any antibiotics we do back at the
camp welcome to follow I'm not following
you anywhere that's why he go get it he
comes back with what I need the deer is
all yours anyone else shows up you put
one right between my eyes that's right
two bottles of the penicillin in a
syringe make it fast go on shoot him
shoot him
I'll take that rifle course [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
him judo come dude him in that batch you
know get him he's probably gonna be a
while you uh why don't we take some
shelter from the cold bring him with us
bring that there with us betch that's
that dragon-like my wife dragged me
through three years of marriage go ahead
ah out that there's like I'm still alive
guys can you wait there you know you
really shouldn't be out here all on your
own I don't like company I see what's
your name Cameron they ask why look I
understand it's not easy to trust a
couple of strangers whoever's heard you
clearly care about them sure it's gonna
be just fine it's for toxic shock
syndrome we'll see I can't get tampons
fast enough and uh oh great
you got another gun sorry I really like
my rifle back no you have your pistol
yes chef I can't use that thing I've had
some practice
no matter what we have to keep them out
but I always had this can I board this
it's like [ __ ] windows okay I [ __ ]
cover the windows with what Oh like
physically comfort or okay how do I
[ __ ]
yeah come on great no more [ __ ] ammo
you aren't kidding you're a better shot
for that thing Oh get your own damn hand
glad this inter I'll carry [ __ ] halo
help me with this thing ok say this is
what happens when you try and help it
wow you like that reload this [ __ ]
video somewhere Emma here you go
chef okay like my weapon back I can't
set a lot of guys [ __ ] bail on bets
hey loud what's all that yelling what is
all that yelling they don't say you're
like yelling screw it we're getting out
of this this way why there's so many in
the [ __ ] looks
give her this batch you're here okay do
you know where you're going never set
foot in this place great not yet oh I
need this lucky break it's clear uh you
are onion I take this shot wait where
the [ __ ] this guy go oh yeah I'm all
scary dude oh [ __ ] how you holding up
you don't need to worry about get use
those hand pounce hi stay close come on
oh great hey kid you all right fine now
Beth wickers every now like
okay okay gosh at a [ __ ] ok I can't
forget her again here you are okay I
need this [ __ ] no it's not like that
lack bladder okay I guess I'm the one
has to get it
yeah she traveled from here Jesus uh-huh
all right get there's others i know
there
yeah how Fox am I am i doing up here ok
this is the ladder and we should figure
out [ __ ] get that letter
how the heck
okay I got [ __ ] [ __ ] okay and that's
thank her second year pick it up there I
like it hmm oh I had to boost this guy
nice it was not [ __ ] how that I go
ahead I'll get all way back there okay
okay okay here we go
oh are you serious all I do is boost him
he said right there is low enough for a
boost [ __ ] all the way across oh all
right here pitch here come here boost me
up now bets ready all right is left on
there what do I shot him and then when
the guy came I shot him to look who's
that I'll take highlight the strangers
are ya okay I'm [ __ ] alright thanks it
all right are you God like it's you're
gonna blood I could drink it baby yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah here ya
betch ok
yeah no [ __ ] okay man I like listen I
don't see anything okay hi hey the sound
is xterra is [ __ ] don't say any one
though oh [ __ ] let me get this straight
first that makes it now gotta make this
man lets a guy tells Bay back out baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a single Oded
not Lena litter yeah I just [ __ ] wait
looks like someone already fought those
things are lost look into these boys
doesn't matter you grab the gear wow
there's so much [ __ ] ok well where the
house backs off
keep your eyes open for anything we can
use see anything to didn't uses so what
do we do there's a big guy coming is
there any other choice
[ __ ] i'm going having my odds off
that cat has max betch
a xanax batch ID oh oh shet shet [ __ ]
liesbet yes oh [ __ ] that's a lot good
love this better work fine that doesn't
feel like it stay focused we'll make set
I gotta make some more of these things
these things are there
oh [ __ ]
a chef Oh
okay what's what's up lower half was
that [ __ ] yeah you know I think we did
it like we killed all of them oh boy I
like this belief okay I'm we're like
this so late anyone yet what kind of
tense up I think I can take care though
okay now okay where's the deer where's
the dare
listen now unfettered no infected what I
tell you how I did it all right let's
head on back check on that bucket bars
that guy ever make it back where's that
buck oh you handled yourself pretty nice
back there huh boo that's hey we make a
pretty good team where's the buck well
yeah lucky lucky no no no such thing as
luck now you see i believe and
everything happens for a reason oh yeah
explain my toxic shock syndrome and I
can prove it t now this winner that's
been especially cruel yeah you could say
out a guy rather a few weeks back I am
that's first he's a group of mana up
nearby town look for food only if you
came back oh [ __ ] either one that killed
he said that the others had been
slaughtered
crazy man oh I get that he's crazy man
traveling a little girl is still on the
injured Joe you see everything happens
for a reason don't get upset it's not
your fault I'm just a kid little James
lower the gun no way David I'm not gonna
let her know her a gun as soon as you
Laura share them gentle now give her the
medicine the others won't be happy about
this yeah well that's not your concern
with a [ __ ] out of the way won't survive
long out there I can't protect you
oh thanks that's the guy in this
shopping [ __ ] scary mackensee oh [ __ ]
the dares watching about the horse is
like wow you've been gone like 30 years
yeah I'll wrap it and we're just like
back yeah it's also long [ __ ] fell
asleep uh and I as gonna go that heroes
SS it down you know I'll stay awake and
enjoy it yeah I know I I my horse not a
batch Sal you know like at least brush
the snow off my face trine kind of uh
huh
how does that I only managed to get a
little bit of food but i did get this
move your arm okay what a puss buddy
might as well take that yeah come on
come on Thank I'm I know better come on
that's trying go through a jack oh my
god well done
hell yeah I could take out that guys
want to look better gonna make dips out
for Harambee